[Music]
is it
morals to ban new BOTS
feelings
I could be wrong what does this guy's
rating
oh okay all the zurk
play another no we're gonna play dragon
oh I forgot to play the French I'm so
sorry passed upon 99 it's too late now
different variations of Sicilian I'll
play Knight f6
and then xe6 we'll see how good he is in
openings
you
these provisional players are we are
always scary but Bishop III makes me
happy
the reason to play the sign is black is
because a lot of players play Bishop III
or Bishop e2 which are both not great
moves now black has all the fun I'm
threatening to take on e4 or I want to
play d5 if anyone wants like a simple
opening against efore I highly recommend
this variation this is so easy to play
when white goes wrong
before whites was not Bishop III
but it's night b5 night db5 a lot of
players don't know to play that so
anyway hey some bits
10 kills
you're the other cheek
100 bits he takes
cure
and there's so many targets in the
center
just take the Knights debating whether
to play Queen h4 check and take with the
Queen
I shouldn't spend too much time on this
I'll just play Queen age for
I'm take here
up apiece
um I will say I teach a lot of students
this opening for black especially those
who are just like starting building out
an opening repertory because just
because it's so simple and most white
players don't know to play Knight db5
unless they're like expert level so back
to tournament still provisional in
classical chess I have ten points
already won two games in a row I won
three games in a row by berserk two
names in a row
oh because that night a two game
so our first game was just really long
so it helps when I beserk